[Music]
a family is suing meta
because they believe instagram gave
their daughter an eating disorder that's
probably true
that's probably [ __ ] very true okay
hold that as i give you more details let
me know when you've like untethered
yourself i've untethered i think it's
[ __ ]
more critical thing you're already
turning on me let me tell you jump the
gun my emotions got the best you regret
it it's at least
let me tell you a story okay yes so this
is gonna be
uh not what you think it is off of that
one statement
and it's already done
dude he'll be sleeping next to his chick
and then he's like let me tell you this
for
you
it's
three in the morning
you think oh it's probably because
there's so many hot girls and she's
comparing yourself ah that's too basic
what this story really is is there's so
much food vloggers and she's just like
there's so much food in the goddamn
world and then she's eating and she
can't stop eating because it's true your
recommendations wait what kind of eating
disorder
is it the one where they don't eat or
they eat too much the dogs the donate
the donuts oh it's the basic car
yeah it's type eight sorry what's the
real story yeah so that's what's
happening how old is she daughter okay
all right so remember you're keeping
your old feelings don't let go yet well
i'm keeping them forever bro this kid is
13.
she came she shouldn't even be honest
exactly but she's old enough for kisses
though like you know like 13 is
according to mcbee that's a [ __ ] fact
no i don't believe that i don't that's
not my statement behind me
clint eastwood it's also colleen's
feelings now she agrees with that yeah
she's a big fan of that club i'm a big
fan
show this kid
mr eastwood we [ __ ] love it
this kid 13
i
ended up signing out for instagram like
kind of behind her parents back of
course uh so already my personal take
like what that's bad parenting already
at that point right but of course hold
on hold on to what you felt why she got
an iphone at 13 years old
and then she also downloads one of those
apps that changes the icon so it looks
like it's just a calculator you could do
that she's genius
wow
also what generation are these parents
that they didn't know that you could do
that i know i didn't i did not know that
we're [ __ ] huh yeah if we have kids
we're [ __ ] up
i used to do that at school with [ __ ]
windows 3.1
you could change the icons you could
hide games she's smarter than i am like
take a photo and then go to your edited
photos and just do a black box over it
so it just looks like a black
photo in your in your phone crafty
i've never done that scandal
now when i worked at a highrise the
games on my computer were so [ __ ]
boring i would rather work you're
telling me you didn't have oregon trail
or trail
you needed to download oregon trail bro
i think it was hard i would always go
hunting you lose bullets
so this kid is now 19 and has uh had to
struggle with mental health issues
suicidal thoughts oh [ __ ] it's been that
long also yeah and the eating disorder
and everything so now our parents are
suing because i think that instagram is
responsible for my whole thing is look
inflation's crazy all the markets are
wild you gotta [ __ ] try something
you gotta try to come up and you're not
bad not bad meta has a lot of money get
creative yeah that has a lot of money i
mean dude it's like it's like the geico
getting sued right now for the thing we
talked about yeah cause the guy got std
in the car yeah that is confusing though
man cuz like on my feed i have nothing
but um
like kind of like hot fitness models and
then food and then back and i'm just
like yo i'm trying to stay fit but i'm
still hungry and the food is delicious
it's like i can't even like choose do i
want to be fit or hungry i can't be both
that's pretty difficult i think the
parents are just kind of dumb it's like
can't you just tell your kid like that's
not real hello
she changed the app like she didn't
didn't realize until now
is the best dad ever if i was the parent
i am the best parent ever hello
it's not real you freaking idiot
yeah that's what i would tell my kids
five to one bad parenting you still
think it's medicine i think it's mark
zuckerberg's fault how did you do
interesting i'll take it a step further
i think i think the zuck is being
there's one more detail that i can share
that you might win you might win
bring it dude let's go
who invented the apple iphone i think
it's steve jobs fault
damn he's but he's dead now he he
created the zoom function
yeah he was she said big smile i was the
big innovator
so uh one thing that has come into
scrutiny is that if
instagram itself is not meant for kids
to be looking at
why does the social media giant spend
millions of dollars researching and
developing product features that
the algorithm bro but let's be real
though like let's be real like there are
app developers that create this to make
sure that it's really hard for you to
[ __ ] look away it kind of is
reminiscent of jewel remember jules like
how the marketing got really [ __ ]
destroyed because because it's like not
meant for kids but yeah
well that's what they say to save face
exactly on lex freeman's podcast they
had this social media expert on and he's
like a researcher college professor
whatever the [ __ ] but his whole thing is
like
no teenagers should be allowed to be on
social media but why because they have
actual good content they have great
content
we're in competition with all of them
they're taking our jobs and i can't
compete with this bro how much to do
fitness post when they're creating the
best content they have their fingers on
the pulse it's true though you have like
people going over the tick tock like
yikes they're so [ __ ] creative
they're taking a job they have studies
they have studies and practical
application of like
this is definitely not good for
teenagers of course they probably didn't
need studies to tell you why not good
for [ __ ] 40 year olds too and that
was the point he was making right and
it's like yeah it's now it's uh it's
it's pretty much proven that this is
harmful for kids have you ever seen
boomers on facebook dude that shit's bad
yeah yeah you see enough profile pics of
them like looking at it
and they're too busy looking at q and on
and stuff using using their status as a
google well dude we're way too into
comparative reality too where it's like
i'm on my phone and i'm seeing other
people doing [ __ ] but they're pretty
miserable too but then they're not
showing that they're just showing me the
perfect life and so it's like oh i wish
i was like them oh i'm gonna compare
myself to that that's true i never show
that like after my hike i take a picture
by the waterfall all happy and as soon
as the phone goes down i'm crying yeah
if they made it illegal to misrepresent
your happiness level on social media
they'll be dope damn
so many people would be out of business
how do you audit it yeah that's touching
on so many different you just have a guy
go to your you have a guy visit you he
just comes to your door and goes
come on really
come on that'll make you crack yeah
you're like you got me suckers oh it
takes a little lean like
for real
you uh posted this pretty nice thing
about your wife
do you really love your wifey son of a
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
bob from next door says your wife's kind
of a [ __ ] are you positive
was that creme brulee really the best
one you've ever had in your life in your
life
we're talking life life i don't know
about it i don't know
i have doubts i've done auditors the
auditors is the trick we just need
one-to-one auditors that's it what is
the uh
solution to social media i think social
media is a tool how you use it is
entirely up to you and it's kind of a
nick
okay and how do you [ __ ] use it
you use that as a tool or as a crutch
yeah what's yours huh huh which one
really he uses to jerk off yeah yeah
it's my tool as a crutch
that's how i use it i use it to escape
yeah it's okay i use it to watch haas
bulla videos that is the [ __ ] that's a
good news are you a fan of haas bulla no
have you seen him you know who he is
do you know who he is no oh he's just a
little kid you don't know who else bull
is he's like this little kid but he's
not the baby man
you've probably seen him
yes i don't know the name but yes are
you a fan
um
yeah there's a right answer i guess
[Applause]
yeah how could you not be a fan that
could i wonder what he's gonna grow up
into
he's already grown up
he's just trying to spread the word of
islam
uh like 19. okay what is he doing he
spreads the word of islam well he's
doing interviews really nice what we all
should be doing
i like during his interview he was like
i don't watch cartoons i'm not a kid i'm
a full-grown adult he's like my brain is
fully developed i'm like he has
chocolate all over his face from eating
chocolate ice cream chocolate sauce yeah
but that was
you know he was hungry and he's like i'm
a full-grown adult i don't watch
cartoons you ever seen him feed a monkey
forget about it that's what i'm saying
the best content there is him holding a
gun him holding a briefcase and holding
anything very adult is a leg i'm getting
hit in the face with a yoga ball
while he's doing the wrong machine i
want to know what zuckerberg had to say
about this he said shut up
he hit back at claims saying that his
platforms were detrimental to oh wait he
hit back at the people saying that it
was detrimental by replying with
he thought that
his social media made difficult times
better rather than worse
well yeah it's how you use it it's how
you use it it's how you use it but for
the context of a 13 year old girl
probably not the best thing yeah i think
developmentally i think like i mean
we're [ __ ] we've already been decided
that we're idiots so we wouldn't look at
[ __ ] and use it badly
we're developed
you said you said the parents didn't let
her have one so she faked one yeah no i
mean what that's too [ __ ] do as a kid
like but then that's what it means like
as a parent you should be able to find
your kids dumb ass tricks like that yeah
you're pretty crafty yourself my friend
yeah
you're a crafty fella i don't know that
i could figure that out
i don't know i didn't get away with too
much i could barely find out how to find
jk news reels i'm always like hey guys
show me how to get on this [ __ ] real
[ __ ] but also we had [ __ ]
generational asian parents that aren't
gonna know [ __ ] but like now it's like
what's your excuse if you're like an
american parent that you have a
smartphone yourself exactly exactly yeah
yeah i like social media because it's
just my whole life i will never delete
it dude i mean i've made so many friends
like real life friends from i made a
whole career out of this yeah
i'm addicted to social media what do i
do yeah you should put 988 on instagram
like oh need help
tap like a little tap yeah but no one's
going to [ __ ] pick up
that's just not
fixed yet you know need help yes i do
can you help me order the pizza what if
it's a bot
the way that they have like bots for
like amazon
they're not good enough yet they're real
alexa can barely talk to me about [ __ ]
it's a one-way conversation yeah it's so
you're not a fan of ai mental health
counselors all she does is pull up
wikipedia i could [ __ ] do that you
know dude i love coming home sometimes
and like uh i hear my wife and she's
like
in the living room and she's clearly
been talking to alexa for a long time
like she's having a like tell her a
[ __ ] story
and then she'll
like it's just alexis telling her story
and then nicki is like pick choosing
your own adventure with the story oh
cool but i'm like you're the only person
who is using this in the world right
wait you could do that i didn't know
yeah i don't even know you could do that
she sits there and does it all the
[ __ ] time i yell at alexa i go alexa
shut the [ __ ] up and then she was like
i'm sorry i didn't know what i did wrong
you better you better watch batmouth and
alexa dog you know what i mean she might
come to the sheets she's going to
remember well i guess we can't be mean
to our our uh our products like that
you're never seeing south park they're
gonna [ __ ] you up dude no no crazy they
people don't forget do you have smart
fridge yet no but i have a smart air
purifier dude [ __ ] is a smart air
purifier this is what this is what it is
i walk into the house no it's like it's
like so many bucks it gets so triggered
even the alexa i'm like what is this for
dude you go you go alexa turn on the air
and then she just does it
just push the button can
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you